so who has used crowdsourcing before for
anything at all okay a few people have
you had trouble with people on
Mechanical Turk or CrowdFlower
notes doing exactly what you asked them
to do yes so it's quite a it's quite a
common problem and it's not that
surprising as well if you consider that
the people are getting paid literally
pennies for four tasks but it's not the
end of the world there are things we can
do to fix that and that's what I'm going
to talk about
there are basically three parts of this
talk I'm going to tell you about the
data that we have so the whole talk is
centered on the problem that we
specifically had at rainforest but I
think some some of the techniques will
be applicable to to everything but we've
played the problem I will tell you a
little bit about the data I will
describe the model that we used to solve
the problem and finally some practical
things about how to deploy something
that you created so the data to explain
it I have to tell you a little bit about
what Trent or this does but I'll keep it
short
we provide QA is a service so if you can
do functional testing by writing plain
English so if you're booking the comm
for example you would write something
like I want the user to go to the home
page type in type in this URL press
Enter login with these details and are
you on your profile page and then a
tester comes along they would reduce
description follow the instructions say
yes no and this way they can find bikes
because we deal with humans we need to
verify their work and we use machine
learning and lots of lots of sort of
manual work for that
so I already told you what the customers
do and what the testers do they come to
our websites or go to Mechanical Turk
and get the tasks and then they are
shown the instructions they supposed to
follow and terminal in which they see a
virtual machine with the right browser
and everything set up for them to
to follow the test and the problems are
that some testers actually most of them
are really good but there is of course a
minority of people who always just try
to click yes yes yes yes yes everything
is okay just pay me money and don't
waste my time so we have to we have to
deal with that and though I would deal
with that by having this thing that
predicts whether the testers input
represent an honest job or not it's also
a trained machine learning model that
does the prediction based on hand
labelled data and another perspective of
looking at this thing is a micro service
that exposes their model through an API
and this is just one solution of one way
of dealing with the problem it's
honestly probably not not the best one
and we do do other things as well so for
example the first thing you should do is
to make sure that your testers are
trained well that you explain everything
that they're supposed to do and which
you expect of them so that when they
want to do good work they are able to
they know what to do it's also our
responsibility to make sure that their
incentives are set up correctly we can
try to build up some reputation so for
example we could give testers and work
that we know the answer to and then
measure their responses and the ones
that always answer Craig he could get
bad reputation and then we could trust
them or we can ask multiple people to do
the same thing and then look for
consensus and finally we can try to
detect bad work from input patterns and
this is this idea is based on the on the
paper from 2011 and we do a little bit
of everything from this but I'm going to
talk about the last one
so how do we capture the data as I
mentioned everything happens in the
virtual machine
everything the testers do is recorded so
their mouth movements the keystrokes the
network traffic between the browser and
the client server and so on and it looks
something like this
so this is a screenshot of what our
testers see without the markings
because we also test rainforest using
rainforest we also have a web interface
so we want to make sure it works well
and here you can see that the tester
clicked in server places that the
circles are where the clicks occurred
and where they move the mouse we also
have information about what they typed
and requests between the service and so
on so knowing that what kind of features
could you think of feel free to shout
out anything you can think of speed yeah
that's a good one nothing else okay so
we have things like from mouse we can
get number of clicks number of discreet
mouse moves the speed the acceleration
standard deviation of positions or some
clicks and moves and and all these kind
of things and it's always fun to dream
up new features that that are based on
this sort of primitive data but that
represents represents something and
there are various combinations the the
only kind of interesting thing about it
I guess is how to exactly measure speed
and acceleration it could take the
average but over like a few minutes
that's not really meaningful so we ended
up with histograms so just empirically
figured out what the ranges are and then
arbitrarily bend speed of mouse moves
into into several bins and by the way
scikit-learn is really cool as everyone
probably already knows because you can
get feature importance really easily and
then you can throw 80 features that are
not informative and keep the one
informative and kind of iterate on that
ok so now we have our recorded data we
know what features we can compute from
it but we still want to really do
supervised learning so we need to label
data and that's a major pain so some of
the developers and at rainforest are not
completely happy about it but what they
have to do every day or now every week
is go through an email they get click on
links and label data for me
and this way we managed to get enough
information to to build up a dataset
now that we have enough of its we don't
have to do it every day and it's it's
kind of chugging along and it's working
pretty well the question there is how do
you select the data to be labeled
because we have I don't know something
like 5,000 testers online per day they
do I know tens of thousands of tests and
obviously we cannot label all of it so
which ones do we select to be labeled we
started with just completely random
selection
they are probably better approaches but
that's what we did and then once we had
an MVP something that we felt gave us
good enough performance we started doing
this 50/50 split so 50% of the things
that got labeled every day we're still
completely random but in the second part
second 50% was taken from the the jobs
that that algorithm thought were the
worst
so we cared about catching the sort of
the worst offenders and labeling the
data to make sure we can learn how to
recognize it and there are probably
better strategies so if you have any
ideas I'm really happy to discuss this
yeah okay another problem with that is
that our data set is not balanced
depending on the algorithm this is not
always a problem but we decided to do
explicit balancing before before widget
learning and of course there are
different strategies in our case the
most of the work is good and only a
small fraction is struggling so if you
you can if you use for example something
like a runoff forest but know with no
explicit balancing it will just learn to
label everything as as good work so the
easiest thing to do when you're oh and
by the way there are other algorithms
that don't suffer from this boosting is
probably a nice approach I'm yet to try
that but but so far we would stick with
that so just to introduce
naive some-something I mean it's pretty
obvious if you have lots of blue points
and lots of orange points neon to
balance you can just go to do blue
points
the nice thing about it is that it's
it's really simple conceptually but the
bad thing is that you lose a lot of your
label data you just don't use it
and that's a shame considering how much
effort it takes to get label data and
the way you do it you subsample then you
split your data set it in training tests
and then you train and evaluate and
actually in in this case the order is
not not that important another way is
sort of the opposite of that super
sampling so instead of getting rid of
the blue points you can just create new
orange points deny most naive way is
just duplication this illustration
doesn't do it justice completely because
the points are supposed to be on top of
each other but otherwise you wouldn't
see it the point is that you just
duplicate points and then you're you
give it to your algorithm as this but
it's really important to do your trained
tests before because if you first do
super sampling and then you split your
data set into training tests you have
probably duplicated samples in involve
things which will obviously give you
wrong idea of your numbers and there are
also other more more involved in more
intelligent ways of of doing the same
thing you could try to super sample
using some kind of interpolation if you
know you can assume something about the
space of all the things that you're that
you're measuring your samples and you
can do clustering if you think that
clusters in your data and then you can
sub sample just for example taking the
cluster centers to have a representative
sample of your data and so on and so on
okay so we we're just doing some
sampling it works well enough for now
and we put it in the runner forests as a
binary classification task there isn't
really much to be said about that it's
pretty straightforward the only
remaining question is how you choose
your parameters so like the number of
trees the depth the number the moon
samples per leaf node and so on
so for now I just have a simple random
search through some predefined space but
again if you have used something like
hyper opt or Auto ml which are things
for to find sort of an optimal set of
parameters I would love to hear about
that and I would love to try them out
the the final thing about the the model
is that instead of getting just simple
classification we just get the
probability because that allows us to a
little bit more flexibility we can
modify the threshold at which we think
we've classify something as good work so
the final ingredient is how to put this
in production that was me awhile ago I
did some experiments in Jupiter and I
thought okay I'm done right so I get
good enough scores and then I was asked
okay so now implement it and I didn't
quite know how to do this so basically
what we need is some way of because
because we're webapp some way of
exposing the predictions of the model
through HTTP so that's the basic idea we
have our main app which is unfortunately
written in Ruby but don't blame me for
that obviously I didn't want to write
like ports parts of scikit-learn to Ruby
that would not be fun so it's a separate
service that justcome communicates over
HTTP
obviously the application has a database
that it needs to talk to you and get
information from and this picture is
enough for day-to-day operation once you
have trained model you get the data from
the database the main app requests like
okay tell me is this job good or not and
guess gets the decision back what's
missing is training how do you train the
model you could do that but it's usually
a bad idea
so if you read about how to structure
micro services the general
recommendation is not to connect two
separate
into the same to the same database
because then if you change the schema
you have to change two things and so on
it's generally a bad idea so what we
decided to do instead is something even
worse I'm just doing the training
locally but for now it's it's kind of
fine we don't get we get lots of data
but it doesn't really change that much
over time so I can just do my training
once a week or once a month whenever
whenever I think we have more data to
sort of to tell us something new and
it's it's good enough so why not another
requirements that should be sort of fast
enough and we also want to know which
model is being used at which time
because we were trained every so often
we might change something for example
change a feature vector and if something
goes wrong we would like to know what's
going on and be able to debug so let's
build an API has anyone used flask cool
so flask is great it makes it really
easy to to build an API it's kind of
like Django but really stripped down and
really easy to use so we to the
predictions we load the trained model
into memory and I start accepting
requests so get a bunch of JSON data
convert it into whatever features you
want give it to the predictor and return
the response again this JSON pretty
straightforward the question is how
exactly do you realize and load your
model in in the same way so everyone
knows what this is this is a pickle so
the answer to how to serialize stuff in
Python is pickle except that's not
always a good idea because well there
are a few reasons first of all there's
this thing called job lip which is
actually shipped as part of scikit-learn
which is much more efficient at
civilizing not by race so if you use job
lip instead of pickle it will your model
will be smaller but more importantly
there are many sort of
more involved and more important reasons
that using something like picker but
also job has the same problems it's not
always a great idea and there was a
great chocolate spike on 2014 explaining
everything the the main problems are
that by using something like this you
have lots of non explicit assumptions
about about what you're doing
so for example the the pickled objects
might not necessarily be compatible
between different package versions it's
difficult to add versioning and if
you're unpacking things that you don't
trust you're going to have a really bad
time because you were open to remote
code execution so don't do that if you
cannot trust the files that you're
destabilizing and all this is by the way
I mentioned in cycads and documentation
and it it also tells you sort of the
best practices of what to save with your
model when you when you want to
serialize it so it's nice to have not on
your model but also your data together
or somehow somehow associated so that
when you so that you're able to re train
your model we created not only
reinstated it's also nice to know the
meaning of a feature vector because as
you're iterating you might figure out
that some features are not important and
then think of new ones that are actually
really useful and that might change the
length of the feature vector and that's
sort of not as bad because it will give
you an arrow pretty pretty quickly but
if you somehow end up with two feature
vectors of the same length but different
meaning you get a prediction but it's
going to be meaningless and performance
curves are also good to to know when you
deserialize the object you can check
whether it's actually doing what it's
what it's supposed to be doing what it
did when you when you see the eyes it so
there's the simple package that I made
that basically does all this for you it
you give it it's basically a wrapper so
you give it the model and all this
metadata and then you just save it you
get one zip file that you can upload to
s3 or whatever and then you can load it
in again and that's pretty simple it's
literally just like one class but it
gives you much more
munition to fight bugs when something
goes wrong and specifically we keep
track of all these things so we get the
data the the names of the features the
hash of the of the gates code that the
generated the data information about all
the packaged versions performance
numbers and when it was created but it's
not addressing all the other limitations
that pickling things generally yes so
for example we don't do anything to
solve the security problems that as I
mentioned so don't DC relies untrusted
code it also increases the size of your
model so if you're dealing with many
terabytes of data this is probably not a
good approach we might change it to just
a reference or a link or whatever but
for now with an MVP it solves our
problem well if you think it would be
useful for you please tell me and I'm
happy to expand it and make it useful
for more people and overall the there
are also some limitations to the whole
approach so if you imagine a test case
that's looking to come for example might
want to write they probably have several
steps so as I go to the home page log in
go to a profile like upload picture
whatever it's a collection of activities
of steps and our classifier at the
moment only works step by step so gives
you predictions aione per step but it's
not exactly what we want we probably
want to tell like okay this whole string
of activities is good or not and we use
heuristic for that at the moment but we
can probably come up with something
better
finally the data capture is not always
reliable it's funny how the sort of the
most mundane feeling things sometimes
give you the most trouble but whenever
your data is not what you expect again
you were you kind of sort of cannot rely
on it to give it a good prediction and
finally there is lots of labeling effort
involved so we kind of grew that's good
out for now but if we ever
to implement a new tracking way or
basically add features that we didn't
have previously we need to start that
labeling from scratch and that will be
massively painful so we can probably
something like maybe not unsupervised
learning but semi-supervised learning or
active learning where the algorithm
looks at the structure of data and then
asks the Oracle which is the the user or
the labeler to label the things that
will give it the most information most
information but again this is this is
future work and thank you I hope you got
something interesting out of it and I'm
happy to take questions
what do you thank you very much it's
happy to learn too many Pokemon
references as a title of your
presentation suggested are there any
questions
way in the back thank you for your talk
I'm interested at the beginning when you
mentioned all the information you are
capturing form from the users the leaks
the speed what are you using is that a
library that is it any open source
library that you use for to gather all
the information it's JavaScript so I
mean they always we always test web up
so they always interact with the browser
so we just watch our own piece of
JavaScript that that does it for us
hi thanks for the talk you mentioned you
use some sampling for model training I
was wondering whether you did some
experiments with plotting plotting the
model accuracy against the degree of sub
sampling and how about no no yes that's
probably something I should do general I
wanted to do some kind of some kind of
benchmark because it's it's a fun topic
to explore and there are many many
papers that give you all these all these
cool stuff something it's not something
or super something balancing techniques
I haven't done this yet thank you
more questions hey maybe I miss it but
what kind of accuracy are you are you
getting out of this with this model
right so we get around 90 percent which
is okay but the the annoying thing is
that I can't verify it but I have a
feeling that a lot of it is due to our
data capturing problems so example we
don't always manage to yeah to capture
everything that we need and then we
looked at the sometimes we have a way of
telling that the testers actually did
something and their actions are not
recorded and that just blows up like it
obviously gives us the wrong wrong
prediction but when humans label it they
label the right thing and these are the
things that we that are pretty dumb
classifier I cannot Kelsey cool thanks
more questions you're doing this on
purpose right make me run would it make
more sense to go into a trust model like
you can give them tests without them
knowing right you know at periodic
intervals you keep giving them and so
that their trust is retained sure sure
so I'm sorry if I wasn't clear that this
is sort of one tool that we have we also
do that so we have sort of honey pots
and we have reputations and and we have
like we talk to the to the testers and
make sure that they sort of they're
happy
so we had like a pet name for this
project which will Robocop because it's
like a robot that that catches catches
people but I think this is like this is
slightly limited way of thinking about
it
so I don't want to give you the
impression that this is the only thing
we do we actually want to encourage
people to to make it worth the time to
do the right thing anyone else question
this is quite interesting actually
so as a website users using it a lot I
think is you can use this methodology to
measure happiness of the website users
not already testers it could be a good
idea have you thought about it no no yes
how would you go about it would you
measure like if they interact more that
means they can interact more maybe
staying on the website but the lazy
users in your case would be on our logos
with the unhappy users right be the one
one thing that I can see being tricky
about it is that our testers know what
they're getting into they know they're
working for us and they know they're
being tracked I would have sort of
problems putting this tracking on
everyone who visits our website because
it might capture things that people
don't want to be captured and then if
you try to measure happiness of people
who work for you they might not always
tell you the
their rights looking at it yeah more
questions okay yes thank you so much
thanks a lot give it to you Anne